some of eSports is most legendary and
adored players have earned almost
mythical titles
there's Daigo the beast
[Applause]
then there's faker the unkillable demon
king like even though I only have a
baton the boy I think is epithet opaque
or maybe a trouble your death mark tries
to clean it up for real oh look at the
class look at the bows thank you
well I was that and of course there's
scream the human headshot machine right
it's their cheese side where they really
struggle now in most cases these
monikers are worn like badges of honor
commemorating the unparalleled skill and
excellence of these Titans in-game but
that's not always the case for nicknames
sometimes they were given for different
reasons just look at an oddball like Ken
Rio Mago Hayashi as proof he's a
longtime street fighter veteran known
for having one of the most vibrant and
unusual personalities in all of fighting
games I bother sir you know who are you
yeah you don't know you oh my god you
spear IVA to the gods now [ __ ] might
refer to himself as the 2d God but he's
actually known as something else and it
has nothing to do with his achievements
were in-game feats no his fans call him
September Mago because he strangely
cursed for three-quarters of the year
okay so if you haven't noticed already
the fighting game community likes to
declare its most elite players gods but
among Japan's many worships deities
there's only one class clown and that's
Mago
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
outside of being known for his
incredible vocal range Magos recognized
for being a skilled street fighter
player and an extremely vital training
partner for some of the FTC's biggest
stars you know Punk basically ran
through everybody and Punk controlled
everyone how were you able to control
Punk it's no secret I have muggle good
hola go where's Drago [ __ ] first began
making his name in Japan back in the
early 2000s placing third at Evo 2003
and winning Tolga key Japan's biggest
national fighting game tournament in
both 2004 and 2005 right around the time
he began calling himself the 2d God as
the years went on magua's profile
continued to rise along with Daigo and
Tokyo he was one of the first Japanese
fighting game players to ever be
sponsored to travel and compete in
Street Fighter 4 making him a household
name in the fgc
hi-yah reset dizzy is the kiddo nice get
off me
[Applause]
Vegas 2015 now unlike his contemporaries
mago wasn't drowning in major silverware
and accolades he performed respectively
but his play was often overshadowed by
his bizarre antics
[Music]
happy birthday the to this him Mago sang
happy birthday to me but around the time
Street Fighter 5 came out Mago became
associated with a strange phenomenon for
whatever reason come every September the
middling to D God would inexplicably
transform into an absolute world beater
and now we're just gonna pressure with
my cry live even though I can't get a
cleaner than he knows look at push the
opponent from the beginning the one who
obvious from this is good for me enough
to do it whatever he had he's got to
bring it out wow that was so risky too
as well for to shoot on this man oh and
Marcos son does the miraculous comeback
and that's gonna be enough
just take the throw yeah I just take it
might as well stop meet it with so I
horrible flask s Mangal didn't interrupt
jab he caught the hit e^x no that's
gonna do it he had enough feed trigger
Mago over haitani
oh wait a second it's not done it's not
so anything is gonna do it
but is bottle necks dead that's the
question Wow Wow
Bongo can't believe it Courtney - sup
into the low forward speed he's reading
it roll star
try to avoid the throw he acts here not
enough to kill but next an angry bird
would not stop and Mago was ready now if
you think I'm talking out of my ass just
take a look at some of these stats
between 2016 and 2019 Mago has only ever
made top eight at Capcom Pro Tour Street
Fighter 5 premiere events six times
before September but of the 21 CPT
premiere events he's attended in
September or later during that same
period he's placed in the top eight
thirteen times that's a better top eight
hit rate than Daigo justin wong and Punk
the numbers don't lie before September
Mago is a good if underachieving street
fighter pro but for whatever reason when
September arrives he becomes one of the
best players in the world no not like
this son of a mistimed kid oh he did it
Mago or is this put his whole life on
the line and he topology can't believe
it shake his hand man okay alright
even though Mago himself doesn't speak
about his annual transformation the mean
surrounding September Mago is one that
the fgc and Capcom have both fully
embraced so obviously there's a legend
of September Mago where the end of the
year you become much stronger does this
also affect your teammates does this
transfer to them as well
of course but in spite of all of Magos
September successes he's equally known
for routinely falling short during the
postseason see the Capcom Pro Tour is
built to qualify players for Capcom Cup
a 32 player tournament with hundreds of
thousands of dollars on the line the
winner takes home a quarter of a million
which is the single biggest prize in
fighting games and for the first three
years of Street Fighter 5 things didn't
go particularly well for Mago there's
the button again but who knows you know
rough interruption really course know
right now we're gonna be it that should
be it bending no cobble drop and it
looks like Fudo is gonna move on
eliminating your pick my picks no it
doesn't mean it and that's going to be
bad Luffy moves on against Fargo and a
jump light head aired every workout
finishes slight there we go the pieces
slide to get the follow up this is not
good one more throw that's right for
three consecutive years Mago played like
a god in September only to finish
17-foot Capcom Cup it was like he'd been
cursed to repeat this pattern forever
fast forward to 2019 and things looks to
be shaping up the same way with
September Mago having his best season
ever he top Aidid four out of five
premier events he'd entered that fall
placing no lower than fourth at four of
them back-to-back but as usual September
ended and with it ma goes rampage he'd
gone from bodying Street Fighter royalty
to drowning in pools at the any regional
finals losing before he could even get
on stream pretty much everyone figured
that yet again Magos Capcom Cup dreams
were doomed
can't you Palma Mago these two played at
Tokyo Game Show it was I feel like it's
DePalma barely barely
meet him Wow yeah he's a lot he's beat
him twice it was like pre September Mago
I also think Ichiban will go on here to
ketover smuggle former map cats match
this would be a kuma versus Karen I
think there's no way to kiddo is gonna
lose that one but Mago had different
plans for 2019 for the very first time
September Mago stuck around for Capcom
Cup in December proving that he couldn't
be confined by the calendar
I'm wearing us
yeah called out that cross can be punch
oh yes no job
this is groovy stone Oh Big Mac is gonna
do it
[Music]
no fear from that LCQ he's moving on in
winners is that me or Oh chica mix
reaching
oh stop it garbage is your true
stay in the game or is it a deep be not
afraid in some us
no she means to move the sweep off the
target combo jump in 50/50 stays in the
front
OOP miss the meeting to the letter yet
snaps try to be sufficient
[Music]
the crush all these beaten
it's not gonna kill he's got NEX gates
for the uppercut doesn't take the red
clutch check it out if Marco has the
resources he needs he's got one more
dive Kiki's gonna use it before the
beach of the runs out he's not
got away from it the first time but he
get the activation after the block
roundhouse and you see Marco trying to
go for that with fear it's not gonna
work out wait a minute now don't get the
wrong idea as well as Mago played he
still didn't go on to win the Capcom Cup
his impressive front may have ultimately
come to an end against phenom and loser
semies but the fact he made top eight at
a tournament he'd become notorious for
bombing out of was a moral victory for
Mago not only did he dish out eles to
some of the best Street Fighter players
in the world but his fourth place finish
was higher than that of any Japanese
player at the tournament it's hard to
say whether or not Mago has truly shaken
his September accurse but even if he
never triumphs at capcom cup he's still
worthy of our admiration he may not have
the biggest trophy cabinet and he might
be regularly out shown by his
compatriots but Magos dogged
determination to prove that he can not
only hang with the best but beat them
gives us all hope that we can reach our
full potential even if it is only for a
few months of the year my god and of
course their scream the human edge Shot
machine I shall do without the
accidental to do it kind of comes off
cringe hey you can you can you can do it
both ways you'll see whatever works the
human edge should machine on tips and of
course their scream the human edge shot
machine
I di think it's too much it's just too
much